Hi, I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about what you do if you
don't have a knife and they have a knife
and they're going to attack you. There
are a ton of ridiculous myths about this
stuff. There are a bunch of bad ideas
out there about this stuff. Um, I'm
going to give you all the information
that I have about this stuff. Uh, and
that comes from a long time of playing
with exactly this scenario and what I've
discovered in it. So, uh, real simple.
I'm going to call Josh out here. We're
going to go to work,
Josh. All right, we're ready to go. Uh,
okay. So, let's talk about what you do
when they have a knife and you don't.
So, first thing you've got to understand
is no amount of skill on earth can
compensate for the advantages they have
when they have a knife. Right? So look,
you could be a real buff yolked like
military trained, have been in a
thousand engagements, right? And and
fought for your life a million times.
And so you will be more prepared than a
grandma who came at you with a kitchen
knife. That's that's absolutely true.
But if you guys are even approaching
equal, the knife makes the other person
in a huge advantage. And I know when I
say that people go, "Well, duh." But the
truth is people in their heads have some
kind of crazy idea that like if I'm
trained in the arts of a screa or kie or
kravagga or some martial art where we
really do stuff that I'm I'm really
going to be advantageous but that's not
true at all. They always have an
advantage and their advantages are are
many, right? So one, someone has a knife
and they go like this, you could quite
easily die, right? So I could cut his
kurateed, he could die. I could cut his
belly, he could go into shock and sepsis
and all kinds of terrible stuff as his
guts are pouring out. So that will
literally kill him. I can't If I was the
world's strongest man, I went like this
with Josh, I couldn't hurt him even a
little bit, right? So maybe he'd go,
"Oh, that didn't feel good because
you're the world's strongest man." But
if I'm a normal dude, I'm not even going
to. That doesn't do anything, right? So
the power advantage of someone with a
knife is way bigger than your normal
power with without a knife. Okay.
Another thing is he's always going to
have a reach advantage. So even if we're
close, right? So look, just stick your
arm out for me. Okay? So look, Josh's
arm and my arm pretty equal in length.
Okay. Now look, Josh is inside of my
body here. He's inside of my body and
I'm not I'm just I'm touching at the tip
of his shoulder, right? So meaning if we
went like this and Josh comes in, he
stabs me. I can't touch Josh, right? So
he's got a huge advantage. And so that
means when we're out here, he can be
tacking out my arms and all kinds of
things constantly. So he has huge
advantages as far as his reach goes as
well. So he just he's he's in a way
better position with a knife. So as the
person without the knife, you have to
respect that first and foremost always.
You can't in your head say, "Oh, in
class last night, I learned how to do
ski, so I'm I'm totally ready." Right?
So you're totally not ready. Okay. So I
got to respect the weapon. And the first
thing I do with that is of course I try
to maintain distance. Now I want to
maintain uh the onestep distance with
the knife in his hand. Right? So meaning
that if he stuck his arm out right now,
this is now my eye because I include the
knife in that range. Now all this is
doing is this range plus gives me enough
reaction time to him. And I think that
can kind of be a hard thing to
understand, but you know, so if if I
went, you know, say a couple steps from
Josh, right? So I'm a couple steps out
from Josh. I know when Josh is walking
towards me, so I can start walking out,
right? So I have a huge advantage in
that, or not advantage, but I have a
huge neutralizing factor in that I can
see him coming way in advance. But if
we're in this distance, Josh can move
his arm so fast that I just don't have
the reaction time to deal with what he's
up to. Right? So, my first way of
respecting this guy who's got a weapon
that will kill me at any time is to give
as much distance as humanly possible.
And I'm always first and foremost
struggling for that distance. So, if
there's a struggle in it, it's me
struggling to maintain distance while
he's trying to chase me down. So, I'd
like to always stay at distance. Okay.
Now, if the distance gets broken down,
he get broken down for a few reasons.
He's just lightning fast and I can't
keep away from him faster than he can
come in. Two, he gets me in a corner so
I can't get away anymore. has got me
boxed into a corner in some kind of way
that I can't get out. Or three, he
surprises me, right? He's like, "Hey,
Josh," like, "Hey, look over there." I
look over there and then he comes and
kills me, right? Okay. So, those are the
three ways in which I'm not going to be
able to make that distance anymore. The
second that the distance is broken down,
I need to go active, right? So, there's
kind of a a middle ground. It's the
dangerous ground. Right? So, if we have
our MAI distance, so this distance plus,
right? So, if I'm greater than this
distance, fantastic. That's that's where
I want to be. Okay. If I'm inside of
here, that sucks because he can stab me.
But I can also start to work with the
knife and I can grab on possibly get it
out and all kinds of other things.
However, there's a distance that's right
in
about here, right? So, probably right
about through there. That's bad for me,
right? Real bad. And so, that d that
distance, I can't be there for any
length of time at all. I need to be
moving closer to him if I'm if I'm at
that distance or finding a really good
way to escape that. So I have to use a
suppression method in some way. Right?
So meaning when Josh is coming with the
knife, I have to in some way start to
suppress this. Now basically all I want
to do is press this knife back towards
Josh. I want to press it into him. So
that's what I'm thinking first and
foremost. And if the knife keeps coming
out, then later I can isolate the knife
and get it out, right? But I want to
press it in. And that's what I'm
thinking. Okay. This is what I think the
root of Ido is. If you look at older
style jiu-jitsu is like Josh coming with
an overhead strike and I just uh just a
showman. Yeah. I press press press.
Right. So that's what I'm looking to do
is just press into him. Now if I do that
he can't stab me while I'm pressing him.
Right. So the second I go oh contact I
just shove that arm in towards him.
Right now either I move him which is
fantastic or he doesn't move but his arm
gets locked up and that's fantastic. And
then from that position I can isolate
the hand and work from there. Right? So,
if I'm in the no man's land, I have to
push deep into Josh, right? And I want
to press that hand into him and
suppress. Now, when I'm pressing into
Josh, I want to be kind of careful with
the way I'm suppressing his his body,
right? So, meaning if Josh has the
knife's out, okay, and I am suppressing
like this, and he pulls the knife back
across my hands, he slices both my hands
open and now I'm going to lose a lot of
functionality like this. I need that
functionality. So, really what I want is
this kind of suppression instead. So he
pulls it back and that hits no no no
vital areas. Right? Now that's different
than this. Right? So this I don't want
because that's all arterial. Everything
in here is arterial, meaning it's
oxygenated blood. I'm going to go down
quicker than if he cuts this. But this
is the bones on the outside of my arm.
So if he comes across that, it's
probably not going to cause any serious
damage, right? There's no big ligaments
here. There's no arteries here. It's not
that vascular right here. Right? So this
area of the bone right here is where
you're looking to suppress with. Right?
And then as you get into a better way to
control, then you can start to control
with your hands. But you need to be kind
of careful of how you're getting at that
arm when you suppress. And so it needs
to be in some way that you can go from
here to here. You shouldn't think hand
first, right? Which is what we tend to
do. And you see this all the time, see
it in our drills all the time. So if
Josh is moving the knife that I'm going
like this constantly to just just
lightly move it. Yeah. So I'm going like
this constantly and every single time
I'm getting my hands cut, right? So I'm
getting my hands cut as I'm trying to go
like this to stop him. That's bad,
right? I really want to kind of be
pressing like this, right? doesn't have
to look there's if you look at modern
combives people like to do this stuff a
lot like ha you cannot get me right so
it's that's not quite that necessary but
koutay this thing that we practice all
the time this thing does exactly that so
as he comes boom like this right I did
exactly what I needed to do I got in
here and got to the knife and I can
start to work the knife okay so one I
want to give him as much distance as
possible two if he's pressed it in so I
can't make distance I need to get that
suppression and I need to get in close
to to do some kind of work to disarm
that knife. The way I'm going to disarm
that knife is to isolate it and then pop
it out. And I've done a million videos
on that. I'm not going to waste your
time right now with that. You can look
at it. But so from here, I'm basically
going to need some kind of grip lock and
then I'm going to work some kind of
disarming technique. Okay. Now, another
thing we have to talk about that I think
I haven't talked about much in my videos
yet is the fence, right? And I'm going
have to go other hand real quick so it's
easy for them to see this. Okay. So, if
Josh is uh go forward for me first.
Okay. So, Josh is here and I go in to
get to that knife and he's scared that
I'm going to grapple with him and take
the knife from him, he's going to fence,
right? So that's what he's going to do.
Okay, you can spend no time here because
time here, this is all inside the no
man's land, right? And he's perfectly
locked you into that no man's land. And
all he's going to do is hunt and peck,
right? So he's going to hunt for a spot.
He's going to peck it. Now I'm going to
try and do this. Okay, let's say I catch
him in here. This is what he's going to
do when I catch him. Okay, I'm not going
to keep him, right? So it's it I cannot
stay here. I can't continue to struggle
forward on the knife, right? So I I
can't be thinking in that way. So what
do I do? Well, I do all the classic
iikido techniques because they teach us
about this position whether we realize
it or not. Okay, this is basically
moonet dori, right? Okay, what am I
going to work? I'm going to try and work
sto maris from here. I'm going to try to
work ei from here. I'm going to try to
work triangles from here. Now an
interesting thing about the triangle
that maybe you think isn't true, but
look, if I come out here when he starts
hunting to get me, oh look at that. My
triangle can keep him from stabbing me.
So, if I triangle his fence, essentially
I'm fencing his fence. It makes it real
hard for him to stab me. Not impossible.
I wouldn't want to hang out there all
day, but but that's what I'm looking
for. Now, if you do manage to get a hold
of the hand, you can work that into your
disarming, right? So, let's say he's
fenced me and I do manage to get a hold
of the hand and he can't pull it away,
right? Which is probably he's probably
going to get it. I can use all of this
as part of my getting in, right? So, I
can use the whole kind of thing as one
one idea. But understand the second he
fences you, the second you see that hand
start to come out like that, you can't
stay here. You have to be working Tino
Hinko, right? And that Tino Hinko is
going to be one of the basic Tino, but
that's the objective. And quit worrying
about the knife because it's going to
stab you anyways. So if you hunt the
knife, I guarantee he'll hold you there
and stab you. But if you work the hand
that's holding you, you're much more
likely to get free. So that's a real
basic way of how you approach someone
who has a knife when you don't have a
knife. That I did leave off some
important things you should think about.
throw right? So, I think that's
number one. Start throwing all the
you can throw. So, you know, if I if I
see a guy with a knife and I'm like,
"Hey, man, cool out." I'm picking up
everything and I'm hucking it at him
because I want him to freak out and
leave. That's what I want him to do,
right? To like lose his nerve and
hopefully other people see me throwing
and they come throw too. And
then he goes away, right? So, I want to
throw If I can get any kind of
longer weapon in my hand, I want to get
a longer weapon in my hand. Now, I don't
advise going to a shorter weapon because
that's going to get you in a bad way.
So, I got some brass knuckles. I'm going
to put them on and all that's stupid
idea. I've got a knife. I'm going to
pull my knife. That's a stupid idea. But
I'm going to take my coat off and whap
it at him. Okay, that's good. I'm going
to pick up a chair and hit him with the
chair. That's a great idea. I'm going to
pick a fire extinguisher, spray him with
him, and conchk him with it. That's a
good idea, right? So, anything I can get
in my hand to help me deal that's with
that weapon that's a longer offers me a
length advantage over that weapon,
that's what I'm going to do, right? So,
so if I could get something in my hand,
I would get something in my hand. I left
that off because I was assuming there
was absolutely nothing in the hand. But
if you can put something in the hand, do
it. So that's your basic idea of what
you're going to do when someone has a
knife. That's a much more realistic
approach than this like I'm going to do
all this stuff. Now, that's not saying
that you don't need to know disarms and
stuff because a situation might arise
and you might need to use the disarm.
But it's just your key idea is to stay
at distance. That's your number one idea
and that's what you're always working
for. And only if that distance breaking
breaks down do you start going to other
things. You don't want to try to
grapple. If you saw the video with Maya
and Josh, Maya grappling with Josh was
way worse for her than Maya trying to do
Iikido, which is keeping that distance
with Josh. Right. So, all right. I think
I've ended this video like three times
now. So, I'm really going to end it this
time. All right. So, I'm Christopher
Hine. This is Joshua Tehi. My salon
McDaniel's behind that camera right
there. And we'll see you in the next
video. Hey, I'm Christopher Hine. So, if
you made it all the way through this
video, chances are you kind of liked the
way I presented stuff or were so
irritated by it that you wanted to watch
more of it. So, I have a Patreon page.
Maybe that's just for you. You should
check it out. There are literally
hundreds of videos on that Patreon page.
I've been making videos for Patreon
since I think 2020 or 2021. Uh, and I've
been making somewhere between two and
five a week. So, there are tons of
videos up over there. So, you might want
to check that out. It's patreon.com
Christopherhein. Uh, hope to see you
there.